Ah... J'suis vraiment bien, là.
Pourquoi t'es bien?
Tu veux pas juste kiffer et pas te poser de questions?
Mais juste celle-là:
Pourquoi t'es bien?
Bah y'a le soleil, la piscine, la boisson...
Y'avait toi avant que tu sois chiant.
Et dans deux heures?
Bah dans deux heures j'en aurai marre.
Pourtant c'est le même soleil, la même piscine, la même chaleur, la même boisson...
Peut-être même que je serai plus relou...
Yo! Moi je vais vous dire pourquoi.
C'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode du coup de Phil
Aujourd'hui on va parler du désir de Schopenhauer.
[Générique] Le coup de Phil [Générique]
Dans la vie, si vous y avez déjà réfléchi,
vous vous êtes rendus compte que la satisfaction ne vient pas d'elle-même,
et il y a satisfaction parce que ça comble quelque chose,
et il y a satisfaction parce que ça comble un désir.
D'ailleurs c'est la satisfaction de ce désir-là.
Et quand ce désir est satisfait, il cesse, parce qu'on lui a donné tout ce qu'il voulait.
Alors non, ce n'est pas tout désir qui cesse, sinon ce serait trop facile,
C'est juste que tu vas te mettre à désirer autre chose.
Mais ton désir, qui était à la source de ta satisfaction,
vu qu'il cesse,
ta jouissance, ton kiff, qui venait de cette satisfaction-là,
elle cesse aussi.
(soupirs)
Un bon café, là...
En fait, une fois qu'on a atteint l'objet de notre désir,
on revient au stade où on était avant de vouloir satisfaire ce désir.
C'est en tout cas la thèse que défend Schopenhauer.
Faut choper qui?
-nhauer, Arthur Schopenhauer. C'est un philosophe allemand du 19ème siècle,
qui a vachement inspiré des mecs comme Nietzsche, ou encore Freud,
au point où Freud a avoué avoir arrêté de lire Schopenhauer parce qu'il avait peur
que cela l'influence trop dans sa pensée.
David Guetta a dû faire pareil avec Mozart.
Son oeuvre principale s'appelle "Le monde comme Volonté et comme Représentation",
et vous trouverez à peu près toute sa pensée dedans.
Pour l'anecdote, parce que j'aime bien les anecdotes,
il a légué une grosse partie de sa fortune à son chien et à sa gouvernante...
pour qu'elle s'occupe de son chien.
Après il faut savoir que la pensée de Schopenhauer est quand même grave pessimiste,
et rien que dans cette vidéo vous allez en avoir un aperçu.
Alors déjà, pour lui, le bonheur, c'est négatif.
(voix off peu enthousiastes)
Alors, ce n'est pas négatif dans le sens où cela va nous faire mal,
ou alors dans le sens où il ne faut pas aller le chercher,
c'est qu'en fait, le concept même de bonheur, c'est la négation d'un truc.
(voix off peu enthousiastes)
Il faut enlever quelque chose pour y accéder.
C'est un peu ce que nous avons vu toute à l'heure avec la satisfaction et le contentement,
en fait,
la satisfaction et le contentement, c'est l'arrêt d'une douleur ou d'une privation
qui vient d'un désir.
Oui, parce que si tu désires beaucoup quelque chose, et que tu ne l'as pas,
tu souffres.
C'est pour cela qu'il dit, d'ailleurs, la phrase:
(on entend l'extrait de la vidéo avec la citation de Schopenhauer)
(sifflotement)
Et il va même plus loin, parce qu'il sépare clairement le moyen qu'on a de ressentir
la douleur, ou la souffrance, par exemple,
par rapport au moyen qu'on a de ressentir de la satisfaction.
En fait, pour lui, la différence entre les deux c'est la médiaté:
il y en a un qui est immédiat, qui va venir à toi sans intermédiaire, directement;
c'est ce qui concerne la souffrance, la douleur, la privation, le besoin...
Par exemple, si tu as soif, ça va venir à toi directement, sans intermédiaire, immédiatement.
Par contre, quand tu bois,
tu te désaltères, tu as une certaine satisfaction,
parce que tu as eu un désir avant: la soif.
Donc, c'est indirect.
En fait, d'une manière générale, les avantages ou les biens que tu as en ta possession,
tu n'en as pas vraiment conscience, ou tu ne les apprécie pas vraiment,
en tout cas pas à leur juste valeur.
Tant que tu les as, tu considères presque que c'est normal de les avoir.
Avoir une meuf qui t'aime? Ouais, normal.
Mes parents veillent sur moi? Normal.
Avoir des amis pour s'éclater avec,
avoir un téléphone portable,
avoir un corps qui fonctionne,
avoir un énorme pénis?
Ouais, tout ça, c'est normal.
Alors qu'en fait non:
je pourrais très bien ne pas les avoir!
Mais cela, tu ne t'en rends compte que si tu fais l'effort d'y penser.
C'est indirect, en fait.
Je vous ai dit que c'était un peu pessimiste.
(musique triste)
Tout va comme vous voulez, monsieur Schopenhauer?
(soupir)
J'ai une vie de merde.
Elle est pas si mal, votre vie.
(musique joyeuse, de fête)
Ouais, j'avoue, allez!
Ibiza! Wouhou!
Mais il n'est pas si pessimiste que ça, parce qu'il essaye de nous apporter des solutions.
Déjà, il nous dit que l'intervalle entre le désir et la satisfaction ne doit être ni trop long, ni trop court.
Bon, ok, on ne va pas aller hyper loin avec ça.
Mais pour lui, il y a d'autres solutions qui permettent de s'échapper de cette pendule qui va de la souffrance à l'ennui.
Alors il y en a une que l'on développera ensemble plus tard,
parce que c'est très proche du bouddhisme, de la maîtrise des désirs, etc.,
et l'autre, c'est l'art.
En gros, on va s'élever de ce ping pong incessant et on va arriver
à une contemplation désintéressée.
Mais, selon lui, ce n'est pas quelque chose qui est accessible à tout le monde.
En vrai, j'aurais pu m'arrêter là,
mais vous n'auriez pas eu toute la saveur qu'il y a derrière.
Et pour cela, j'ai besoin de vous introduire un autre concept de Schopenhauer,
qui s'appelle la Volonté.
Vous vous souvenez, quand j'ai parlé de son livre?
"Son oeuvre principale s'appelle "Le monde comme Volonté et comme Représentation",
et vous trouverez toute sa pensée dedans.
Et d'ailleurs, pour l'anecdote..."
Non, avant de faire une anecdote, on va juste revenir sur le titre.
"comme Volonté et comme Représentation": c'est une dualité qui est très inspirée de Kant,
donc on aura l'occasion d'en reparler,
mais moi je veux juste m'arrêter sur le mot "Volonté", ici.
En fait, la Volonté, avec un V majuscule, chez Schopenhauer,
ça n'a rien à voir avec le mot volonté comme on a l'habitude de l'entendre;
c'est plus proche de la Force dans Star Wars, par exemple:
c'est une force qui est naturelle,
objective,
qui ne veut que se perpétuer,
qui se manifeste dans tout;
ça va du minéral à l'animal,
c'est l'inertie dans la matière,
la sexualité chez le vivant.
C'est un truc qui est très proche de ce qu'on a pu voir chez Spinoza, par exemple,
mais pas que:
souvenez-vous ce que j'ai dit un peu plus tôt:
"... qui a vachement inspiré des mecs comme Nietzsche..."
Et c'est pour ça que Nietzsche a appelé son concept "La Volonté de Puissance".
Tout est lié!
Bref, cette Volonté, du coup, s'exprime au travers de  plein de choses,
et aussi au travers de nous; c'est ce qu'on appelle le "Vouloir-vivre".
Et dès qu'un élément se met en travers de son chemin,
on souffre.
Quand l'effort de la Volonté est arrêté par quelque obstacle entre elle et son but du moment,
voilà la souffrance.
Donc, en fait, la souffrance, c'est quelque chose qui est naturel et nécessaire.
Ça ne peut pas être autrement.
(lit la citation)
Mais quand on contemple de l'art, c'est quelque chose qui est désintéressé.
Vu que c'est désintéressé, c'est un exercice qui se fait hors de la Volonté,
donc on se libère du Vouloir-vivre,
et donc c'est pour ça que c'est une solution pour Schopenhauer.
Boum! Tu la sens, ma grosse intelligence?
Si t'as encore de la satisfaction face à cette vidéo, et que tu n'as pas encore le désir de mater une autre vidéo,
je t'invite à t'abonner, si ce n'est pas déjà fait, pour ne pas rater les prochaines,
et surtout à passer le coup de Phil' à un ami, c'est le plus important.
Je vous envoie du love et de la peace,
et soyez heureux.
J'espère que cet épisode vous aura plu.
Donc, Schopenhauer, c'est quelqu'un qui a été vachement inspiré aussi
par le bouddhisme, quand il a lu l'histoire du Bouddha, etc.,
il a eu quelques révélations, donc on reparlera de tout ça
quand on parlera du bouddhisme puisque c'est un truc dont je vais parler forcément.
Un autre point que j'ai vaguement évoqué,
c'est celui de cette dualité entre le monde comme Volonté et comme Représentation,
je vous ai dit que c'était une dualité qu'on retrouvait chez Kant.
En fait Kant, j'ai fait un épisode, pour l'instant, qui est un épisode sur la raison pratique,
et on va faire un autre truc sur la raison pure,
donc j'en reparlerai à ce moment là.
N'hésitez pas à me suivre sur Facebook, Twitter, Snapchat;
c'est trois réseaux que j'utilise vraiment différemment,
donc si l'univers vous plaît, n'hésitez pas à me suivre là-dessus.
Merci, encore une fois, à tous les tipeurs,
vous êtes au max, vous êtes... (fait un signe de main)
gros love, love, love sur vous,
merci.
Et on se revoit la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo, à la même heure,
soyez là, soyez présents.